und damit herzlich willkommen meine
lieben freunde zu einer neuen mord
vorstellung und zwar von der selfmade
downloadlink ezb rats in der
beschreibung und ja der name verrät
schon was man mit dieser mode alles
anstellen kann
und zwar schon wie ich bin die ganze
zeit bewegen das ist nicht der normale 5
modus nein ich habe eine kamera in der
hand und es ist quasi wirklich so meine
hand ist ausgestreckt so ich habe als
wenn ich hier sein handy nach hätte kann
so blablabla ich mache jetzt 1 11
genauso sieht das ganze jahr aus und
hält sie gar nicht mehr weg machen und
ich zeige euch jetzt erst mal wie das
ganze funktioniert und zwar seht ihr
schon manchmal den f1 raus mache ich
habe ein cell phone in der hand das
findet ihr im kreativ modus unter
verschiedenes ganz unten hier ist das
cell phone bereits smartphone nicht ums
telefon heißt was eigentlich unterschied
zwischen cell vorn und smartphone
schreibt mir das mal bitte und das ganze
kann man sich auch kräften im ganz
normalen survival mode und zwar brauchte
dafür einfach links drei eisenbahnrechts
reise waren oben in der mitte eine
glasscheibe und damit eine glasscheibe
in der mitte einen redstone für die
engine ich mein handy abgewimmelt
ich habe ja schon in diesen zehn
crafting all dies folge nummer eins
blabla gesagt als er richtig cool eine
kamera dazu kommt und jetzt habe ich
einfach sondern mord gesehen wo also 111
von hinzugefügt wird
und ja wir nehmen uns das ganze jetzt
einfach mal können jetzt quasi auch
einfach mal ich gehe jetzt mal in den
game mode 0 einfach mal damit ihr seht
dass es auch geklappt habe ich gerade
dieses ding in der hand
das ist ein ganz normales elf von hier
blabla ich kann also ich hab ja zwecks
und deswegen ist die textur so ein
bisschen handys halt immer noch so
normal die volltext mäßig ich kann jetzt
einfach rechtsklick drücken und dann bin
ich quasi in dieser kamera drin also ich
kann jetzt sehen ok komme ich mache
jetzt 111 kann das ganze auch mit tieren
machen ich habe auf twitter
schon etwas gepostet wo ich in stealth
mit einer kuh gemacht habe
da ist die kuh und jetzt kann ich so
machen so und gleich wenn die ku guck
guck mal qkm bleib hier kuh so und jetzt
kann ich jetzt kann ich einfach
linksklick machen
und jetzt kann ich provider catching
fire safety also das was ich jetzt
gerade seht wenn sich die coop eg als
ganz bewegt aber das was ich gerade wo
ich links weg gemacht habe genau das
gerade wo ich links weg gemacht habe da
ist jetzt halt dieses elfi entstanden
und jetzt kann ich etwas hin schreiben
ich nenne sie zum beispiel die crew und
meine wenigkeit teil 2 so jetzt kann
hier noch nashtec hashtags 11 ihm jetzt
kann ich machen kann offset klicken
und jetzt gleich werdet ihr sehen dass
in dem chat unten links angezeigt wird
dies was hier schon steht dann you can
find yourself anderen schädling genau
dass er jetzt an diese adresse minecraft
cells.com kraft also slasher ingame /
und dann was das für 111 ist da kommt
jetzt einfach mal drauf klicken dann
können wir einfach mal ja klicken
jetzt seht ihr nämlich gerade ein bild
eingeblendet von dem safety wie das
ganze dann aussieht und so wie das ganze
damit quasi auf der website angezeigt da
wird dann auch noch gezeigt zu was für
einer zeit dass aufgenommen wurden was
für ein bio das war was das für ein
wetter war ich ganzen mops in den dingen
gesehen in dem sie vollkommen zum
beispiel hier gerade da sind einfach mal
sechs tintenfische das können wir aber
eben kontrollieren wir können einfach
jeder müssten ja hier irgendwo die oder
6 hinten fischer die wand wohl auch mit
in diesem büro wo ich den self gemacht
habe also das ganz witzig wir können
jetzt hier auch einfach mal die quasi
übrigens derzeit ist relativ cool also
eigentlich ich finds immer ganz cool
also das ist ein zweifel sie doch etwas
größeren insel hier falls ihr den cheat
haben walter steht da wir können jetzt
einfach mal hier noch 111 machen sondern
machen wir nicht so ich hunde inseln ich
das ganze dann einfach mal aber ich
flieg dafür immer einfach so ein
bisschen dass man allein den wolken
macht es mal so die insel und ich 611
techno filter hashtag #tatort bin ich
der rausschmiss 11 modus auch mal dahin
sind noch ein paar inseln
also das ist eigentlich allen in allen
die mod ich wollte euch einfach nur
vorstellen weil ich bei den crafting
ideen so eine kamera vorgestellt und
jetzt kommt einfach ein zelt von hinzu
mit dem man selbst machen kann
es ist richtig cool wir können jetzt
wieder mal auf den link da drauf klicken
so ihr seht wieder eingeblendet ok in
dem bild bin nur ich das da sieht man an
bio misst beach die zeit ist bei 11 24
und das wetter ist immer noch sonnig und
es sieht relativ cool aus also ist die
ganze sache dann einfach eingeblendet
sorgt derzeit das ganze weg gemacht
ich finde die mod sehr cool es fügt
jetzt nix hinzu wo man sich so denkbar
oder mit könnte ich zehn jahre lang spaß
aber es ist einfach ganz cool
funktioniert mit allen möglichen anderen
motto außer mit ballack die kraft glaube
ich downloadlink es in der beschreibung
könnt ihr euch einfach mal rein packen
und es ist ein bisschen cooler als immer
diese blöden der fünf fotos wenn ich
finde das so viel cooler wenn man ihm
ein cooles bild machen will
und ja das würde ich sagen was mit dem
motto wenn ihr weitere max willst wie
ich vorstellen soll oder wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann zeigt man mit einem
mag ich würde mich sehr freuen und also
wenn ich weitere videos machen soll wenn
euch das gefällt und dann würde ich
sagen
sehen wir uns in den nächsten video
wieder